هذا مكان سقوط احد القذائف او الصواريخ
التي اصابت العاصمه كييف قبل فتره قصيره
فقط من الان كنا سمعنا صوت صافرات الانذار
وبعدها سمعنا اصوات ااا المضادات الجويه
وقد حاولت صد الهجمه الصاروخيه التي تقول
السلطات ان روسيا استهدفت عبرها قطاع
الطاقه طبعا هناك اماكن اخرى سقطت فيها
الصواريخ في العاصمه الاوكرانيه كيف رئيس
الاداره الاقليميه العسكريه في العاصمه
اوليكس كوليبا ابلغ ان هناك ضحايا بين
سكان المدنيين وذكر ان العديد من المناطق
بدون كهرباء بسبب قصف منشات الطاقه اليوم
في كياف المعلومات التي لدينا تشير الى
انقطاع الكهرباء
اليمنى لنهار نقدر في العاصمه الاوكرانيه
كيف فيما اعلن عمده كيا فيتال كليتشكو عن
انقطاع المياه في ارجاء العاصمه وان العمل
جاري همم استعاده همم هذه الخدمه المهمه
لسكان العاصمه هناك في هذه الغاره بحسب
السلطات الاوكرانيه قتلى وجرحى وايضا
انقطاع كبير في الكهرباء في اجزاء من
العاصمه وايضا في مدن اخرى ليس فقط
العاصمه بل في مدن اخرى بحسب المعلومات
الوارده من هناك وهذا الاستهداف طبعا همم
هو همم اول منذ تقريبا يوم الاثنين همم
قبل الماضي ايام العشره الاخيره